ERIK DEMAINE: Algorithms
is an interesting area,
because it's very creative to
come up with new algorithms.
There's often many ways
to solve the same problem.
But unlike art
say, in algorithms
there's a quantifiable
measures for how good you did.
What is the running time of
the thing you ended up with?
How much space does it use?
It is efficient?
So it's nice in that
it's easy to evaluate
whether you kind of succeeded.
Did you get the n
log n algorithm?
Did you get the fastest
that's possible?
But it's hard to measure
a student's understanding
because it's like, did
you get the creative trick
that we had in mind,
or find another one
that's just as good?
Students may find a
different creative trick
that doesn't end up with as
good an algorithm in the end.
So we penalize that someone,
but for the most part
we are happy when people
get correct algorithms.
When they understand
the techniques
well enough that they get an
algorithm, it's pretty good.
May not be the best,
but we consider
that much better than they
were using the right technique,
but they ended up using it
wrong and so they end up
with something
doesn't even work.
And that's much more
discouraging, I guess.
But in any case,
in a timed exam,
it's really hard to expect
students to be creative.
So in that setting, it's hard.
We don't expect a
lot of creativity.
We try to keep the
questions relatively simple,
so you need just
one simple idea.
If you're familiar
with the material,
it should come quickly.
It Doesn't always, but--
So problem sets are definitely
an easier way for students
to express creativity.
It gives them a little more
time to think about the problem.
Because some problems are going
to come easy to some students
and hard to others.
It's going to be
different problem set,
so they have a week
to think about it.
And also to talk to others,
we allow collaboration
in the problem sets,
so that makes it easier
to find solutions but
still learn a lot from it.
In the exams, it's a lot harder.
In past years we've tried
take home exams as a way
to more accurately gauge
how creative someone is
in applying these techniques
to design new algorithms.
We didn't do that this year.
It's not clear what
the right answer is.
It's definitely a challenge
in teaching algorithms,
is how to evaluate whether
someone can really apply
the techniques in new
and creative ways.